there's plenty on the agenda in the  first session of Parliament since mais  European elections MEP s have been busy  forming their groups ahead of the  inaugural sitting on July the second the  house will elect its president for the  next two and a half years the vote is by  secret ballot in up to four rounds the  14 vice presidents who replace the  president when absence will also be  chosen along with the five Questers  responsible for administrative matters  affecting members MEP s will form the  parliamentary committees committees  examine new laws propose amendments and  appoint teams to negotiate with the  council in areas ranging from transport  to consumer protection MEP s will debate  the outcome of the June 2019 summits and  discuss EU leaders proposals for the EU  stop jobs including the post of European  Commission President